Hanco runs a shop that sells Vietnamese sandwiches and bubble tea on a corner in Brooklyn. It's a neighborhood favorite, lots of tables, and sunlight streaming in through big windows, crowded most of the day. Not long ago, a customer brought in a menu from a shop that opened up just four blocks away to show to Hanco.
Hanco在布鲁克林的一个街角开了一家店，卖越南三明治和珍珠奶茶。那是附近很受欢迎的一家店，有很多桌椅，大窗户透进阳光，大部分时间都很拥挤。不久前，一位顾客带了一份菜单给Hanco看，那是四条街外刚开的一家店的菜单。
Yeah. When I saw this, I was really shocked.
是的。当我看到这个的时候，我真的很震惊。
OK, so here's your menu. Just read the list of sandwiches from top to bottom.
好了，这是你的菜单。只要从上到下读一遍三明治的列表。
Classic, grilled pork, grilled chicken, sardine, shredded chicken, tofu.
经典款、烤猪肉、烤鸡肉、沙丁鱼、鸡丝、豆腐。
Now let's go to this other one and read.
现在让我们看看另外那一家店，读一下。
OK, classic, grilled pork, grilled chicken, shredded chicken, tofu.
好了，经典款、烤猪肉、烤鸡肉、鸡丝、豆腐。
Or, go to the list of bubble teas. Here's Hanco's menu.
或者，看看珍珠奶茶的列表。这是Hanco的菜单。
Original bubble tea, almond, taro, honeydew coconut, coffee, thai tea.
原味珍珠奶茶、杏仁味、芋头味、哈密瓜椰子味、咖啡味、泰式奶茶。
And the competitive, Henry's.
还有竞争对手Henry's的。
Original bubble tea, almond, taro, honeydew coconut, coffee, thai.
原味珍珠奶茶、杏仁味、芋头味、哈密瓜椰子味、咖啡味、泰式。
Of the 42 sandwiches, salads, appetizers and drinks on Hanco's menu, all 42 are on Henry's in the exact same order, laid out in the same places on the menu posted $0.25 to $0.50 cheaper. And when you hold the two menu side by side, it's the same font, same colors, maroon letters on white. Each one says in cursive, "free delivery on the upper right". The two menus look like copies except for the name on top.
在Hanco菜单上的42种三明治、沙拉、开胃菜和饮料中，这42种全都在Henry's的菜单上，顺序完全一样，在菜单上的位置也一样，价格还便宜了0.25到0.50美元。当你把两份菜单放在一起对比时，字体一样，颜色一样，白底栗色字。每一份菜单的右上角都用草书写着“免费外送”。这两份菜单看起来就像复印件，除了顶部的名字不同。
I guess they're being lazy. They don't want to be great creative. You're just like, "you know what, let's just copy and paste".
我猜他们就是懒。他们不想发挥创意。他们只会想：“你知道吗，我们就复制粘贴吧。”
The three people who owned this new place have all worked for Hanco at some point or another. There was Henry, there was Henry's mom, and there was Hui. Hanco says in retrospect, they were always asking, "how do you make this? What's the recipe for that?" And at the time he thought they were just trying to be helpful, until they opened up their own place and he put it all together.
这家新店的三位老板都在Hanco工作过。有Henry，Henry的妈妈，还有Hui。Hanco回想起来说，他们总是问：“这个怎么做？那个的配方是什么？”当时他以为他们只是想帮忙，直到他们开了自己的店，他才把这一切联系起来。
For two nights after he saw the menu, Hanco couldn't sleep. He had trouble breathing. He wondered if he was having a heart attack. He was really upset.
看到那份菜单后的两个晚上，Hanco彻夜难眠。他感到呼吸困难。他怀疑自己是不是心脏病发作了。他真的很沮丧。
I understand like you want to start your own thing. But you don't have to be identical. Do something different. I mean, even though if you get my recipe, you stole my recipe. Or you didn't steal it. You just know it. I teach you. You know it. You work here for many years, you know the recipe. You start your own business. You open across the street, the next block. I mean, that's your choice. I can't do anything about that. You know, that's how it is. Why do you do identical? Why do you confuse customers? Because customers come to me, "is the the same as Hanco's".
我理解你想开创自己的事业。但你不必做得一模一样。做点不同的东西吧。我的意思是，即使你拿到了我的配方，你偷了我的配方。或者你没偷。你只是知道而已。我教过你。你在这里工作了很多年，你知道配方。你开始了自己的生意。你在街对面、隔壁街开店。我的意思是，那是你的选择。我对此无能为力。你知道，事实就是这样。为什么要做得一模一样？为什么要让顾客困惑呢？因为顾客跑来问我：“这和Hanco的一样吗？”
It has hurt Hanco's business. Sales are down 10% to 15% he said. Meanwhile up the street at Henry's, things are going so badly them Henry and his mom left after just a few months. Now Hui ran the place alone.
这对Hanco的生意造成了损害。他说销售额下降了10%到15%。与此同时，在街上的Henry's，情况非常糟糕，Henry和他的妈妈只开了几个月就离开了。现在是Hui一个人在经营这家店。
So I marched up the street to see what Hui had to say about all of this. Because Vietnamese sandwiches and bubble tea, they're an idea whose time has come, and not just in Brooklyn. They're popping up all over the country. You you buy Vietnamese banh mi sandwiches in Biloxi, Mississippi right now. And bubble tea, you can get it in Idaho. With all that potential and opportunity out there, all that money to be made, why did Hui and Henry imitate this one restaurant four blocks away so slavishly all the way down to the font on the menu? What were they thinking?
所以我一路走到那条街上，想看看Hui对这一切有什么说法。因为越南三明治和珍珠奶茶，它们是一个适逢其时的好点子，而且不仅仅是在布鲁克林。它们在全国各地如雨后春笋般涌现。你现在在密西西比州的比洛克西都能买到越南三明治。还有珍珠奶茶，在爱达荷州也能买到。有着如此大的潜力和机会，有着那么多可以赚的钱，为什么Hui和Henry要如此机械地模仿四条街外这家餐馆，甚至连菜单字体都照搬？他们在想什么？
And when I got to Henry's to ask this-- it's this tiny little shop-- what happened next was very, very strange. There was a man and two women behind the counter. And they swore they had never heard of anyone, anyone, named Hui. "No, no," they said, "This place had a new owner, some guy in Queens name Joey".
当我到Henry's问这个问题时——那是一家非常非常小的店——接下来发生的事情非常非常奇怪。柜台后面有一个男人和两个女人。他们发誓说从未听说过叫Hui的人。“不，不，”他们说，“这家店换了新老板，是个叫Joey的皇后区人。”
Does anyone work here who used to work at Hanco's? I brought a Cantonese translator with me because I've been told the Hui's English wasn't so great. Hui is Chinese, not Vietnamese.
有没有人在柜台工作过，以前在Hanco工作过？我带了一位广东话翻译，因为有人告诉我Hui的英语不是很好。Hui是华人，不是越南人。
I used to deliver food at Hanco's.
我以前在Hanco送餐。
And what's your name?
那你叫什么名字？
Me?
我？
The guy behind the counter got a funny look on his face.
柜台后面的那个男人露出了一种奇怪的表情。
Ling, I'm Ling. Ling, L-I-N-G, Ling.
Ling，我叫Ling。Ling，L-I-N-G，Ling。
Yes, Ling told me he had worked at this place since the very beginning, seven months before. But no, he had no idea who this Hui was. He had never heard that name. When I asked him if they knew anything about how they came up with a menu, if they stole from Hanco's, Ling would say things that seemed to indicate that he had no problem copying the menu.
是的，Ling告诉我他从最开始就在这家店工作，七个月前就开始了。但他说他不知道Hui是谁。他从未听说过那个名字。当我问他们是否知道菜单是怎么来的，是否是从Hanco偷来的，Ling说的话似乎表明他并不介意复制菜单。
If you're like a kung fu student, if the master didn't teach you, how are you supposed to learn?
如果你像个功夫学徒，如果师傅不教你，你该怎么学呢？
And then in the very next, he would say.
然后紧接着，他又会说。
But I won't copy them. We do their own thing. They do their own thing. There's a difference between the two restaurants and we just made a new menu. Take a look at it.
但我不会抄他们的。我们做我们自己的东西。他们做他们自己的东西。这两家餐馆有区别，我们刚刚做了新的菜单。看一看吧。
And, in fact, the new menu was glossy, and multi-colored, and didn't look like Hanco's menu at all. Though, of course, it still contained most of the items from Hanco's menu. "Stop talking about the past," Ling kept saying. "We don't know about the old menu and how it was made, we only know about no."
事实上，新的菜单是光面的，多色的，看起来一点也不像Hanco的菜单。尽管当然，它仍然包含Hanco菜单上的大部分项目。“别再谈论过去的事了，”Ling一直说，“我们不知道旧菜单，也不知道它是怎么做出来的，我们只知道现在的。”
Back out on the street, the translator, his name was Lee, and we couldn't figure out what just happened. Ling had told us that he thought it would be perfectly acceptable if they copied from Hanco. But then he also said that they didn't copy from Hanco. Also, somehow he had never heard of Hui . None of them had. Even though Ling had been at the restaurant since the day that Hui and Henry started it seven months before. None of it made any sense. And it was hard to let it go.
回到街上，翻译Lee和我无法弄清楚刚才发生了什么。Ling告诉我们他认为如果他们复制Hanco的东西是完全可以接受的。但后来他又说他们没有复制Hanco。而且，不知何故他从未听说过Hui。他们都没有听说过。尽管Ling从Hui和Henry七个月前开店起就在那里工作了。这一切都说不通。而且很难就此放下。
They don't know who Hui is apparently.
显然他们不知道Hui是谁。
But Ling worked here with Hui .
但Ling和Hui一起在那里工作过。
He didn't know the name Hui , but he knew the old owner, whoever the old owner was. But basically, I'm pretty sure he does know who Hui is by his body language. He wasn't answering. Other questions he was answering. He just with avoiding the question whenever I mention Hui .
他不知道Hui这个名字，但他认识以前的老板，不管以前的老板是谁。但基本上，根据他的肢体语言，我很确定他知道Hui是谁。他不回答。其他问题他都回答了。每当我提到Hui时，他就在回避这个问题。
Do you think he's Hui?
你觉得他就是Hui吗？
I don't think so. But that would be funny if he was. He did take a while to answer his name his own name. So I don't know if that's really his name.
我不这么认为。但如果他是的话就太滑稽了。他确实过了好一会儿才回答出自己的名字。所以我不知道那是不是他真正的名字。
Let's take his picture.
我们拍张照吧。
I pull out my digital camera, walk back into the restaurant, stand right in front of the counter facing Ling and the two other employees. I say nothing, point the camera. I shoot. I walk out.
我拿出数码相机，走回店里，站在柜台前，面对着Ling和其他两名员工。我一言不发，对准相机。我按下了快门。然后走开了。
Four minutes later I'm back down the street inside the place where I started, the first restaurant, Hanco's. I show Hanco the photo and ask if he recognizes anybody.
四分钟后，我回到了街上，进入了我开始的那家店，也就是Hanco的店。我给Hanco看照片，问他是否认识其中的任何人。
That's Hui with the white hat. I've never seen this one. This is probably his wife.
那个戴白帽子的是Hui。我没见过这个人。这个可能是他老婆。
So we had back four blocks in the other direction to Henry's store. And without the tape recorder on, I explained to Ling that I know he's actually Hui . And I told him that I'm not trying to embarrass him. But please could he just explain to me why he and Henry decided to knock off Hanco's menu so thoroughly and completely. He tells me, basically, that it was Henry's idea. Henry, when I check with him, says that it was actually Hui's idea. But neither of them could actually understand what the big deal was with copying a menu.
所以我们朝另一个方向往回走了四条街回到Henry's的店。在录音机没开的情况下，我向Ling解释说我知道他其实就是Hui。我告诉他我不是想让他难堪。但请他解释一下为什么他和Henry决定如此彻底、完全地抄袭Hanco的菜单。他告诉我，基本上是Henry的主意。当我向Henry核实时，他说其实是Hui的主意。但他们两个都无法理解复制菜单有什么大不了的。
"All restaurants take from each other", Hui told me. You'll have two Japanese restaurants across the street from each other. They'll both sell the same items. That's how it always goes." In fact, Hanco, the guy with the first shop in the neighborhood, Hanco will tell anybody's who is curios that he got the idea for his place by visiting another Vietnamese sandwich shop in New York, one called Nicky's.
“所有的餐馆都互相借鉴，”Hui告诉我，“你会看到街对面有两家日本餐馆。它们卖的东西都一样。事情总是这样的。”事实上，Hanco，那个在附近开第一家店的人，如果有人好奇，他会告诉任何人，他的开店灵感来自于参观纽约的另一家越南三明治店，那家店叫Nicky's。
Sandwiches and bubble tea are this unlikely million dollar idea. It's this unlikely idea, but it started at one job and it spread like a virus through Brooklyn, infecting one small, aspiring businessmen after another, leaving a trail of jealousies, and ambitions, and hurt feelings in its wake. None of these three guys are talking to each other anymore. Apparently a million dollar idea can do that, even if the idea does not make you $1 million.
三明治和珍珠奶茶是一个令人意想不到的百万美元点子。这真是一个不可思议的点子，但它始于一份工作，然后像病毒一样在布鲁克林传播开来，感染了一个又一个雄心勃勃的小企业主，留下了嫉妒、野心和受伤的感情。这三个人现在都不再说话了。显然，一个百万美元的点子可以做到这一点，即使这个点子并没有真正让你赚到100万美元。
Today on our radio show, we have stories of million dollar ideas, some of them with enough juice in them that they're actually worth actual millions, some of them only good enough to turn your life upside down and wreak havoc as you chase after them. At WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, our show in four acts today. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有关于百万美元点子的故事，其中一些充满了潜力，确实价值数百万，另一些则只会把你的生活搞得一团糟，让你在追逐它们时满地鸡毛。在WBEZ芝加哥，这是由公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass，今天我们的节目分为四个篇章。请继续收听。
Act One, Going Up? There's a whole world of engineers and investors who are actively trying to invent million dollar ideas. And in that world, there's something called an elevator pitch, which is pretty much exactly what you would guess it is. It's the pitch that you would make for your product, for your idea, if you bumped into a rich investor on an elevator. Figure you have 60 seconds, what's the vital stuff that will convince them. What are the details that you leave out?
第一篇章，上去吗？有一整个工程师和投资者的世界，他们正在积极尝试发明百万美元的点子。在这个世界里，有一种东西叫“电梯演讲”，这和你猜的完全一样。这就是当你和一位富有投资者在电梯里偶遇时，你会为你的产品、你的点子所做的推销。想象你有60秒的时间，哪些是能说服他们的关键内容？哪些细节你会略过？
This is such a specific skill, apparently. MIT actually has a contest for its students and faculty with thousands of dollars in prices for elevator pitches. There's a little video on YouTube encourage people to pitch in this contest.
显然这是一项非常具体的技能。麻省理工学院甚至为学生和教职员工举办了一场比赛，有数千美元的奖金奖励给电梯演讲。YouTube上有一个小视频，鼓励人们参加这个比赛。
[MUSIC - "SEXY PITCH" BY  MIT $100K ENTREPRENEURSHIP COMPETITION]
[音乐 - 麻省理工学院10万美元创业竞赛的《性感演讲》]
Get it? Tim Rowe was a judge at this year's elevator pitch contest. He's an investor. And he runs what he describes as basically a big frat house, filled with start-up companies called the Cambridge Innovation Center. He told me, "Elevator pitches actually do happen in real life." He's even witnessed one in an elevator. But usually they go like.
懂了吗？Tim Rowe是今年电梯演讲比赛的评委。他是一位投资者。他经营着他所描述的基本上是一个大型互助会，里面全是初创公司，叫剑桥创新中心。他告诉我：“电梯演讲确实发生在现实生活中。”他甚至在电梯里亲眼见过一次。但通常它们是这样的。
You're walking through the halls at, say, MIT. And you see a professor there. And the professor is standing with a visitor. And the visitor turns out to be a famous venture capitalist. Right? And the professor turns to you and says oh, Joe, this is so and so. He's looking around for interesting things to invest in. And this is your moment, right?
你走在麻省理工学院的走廊里，看到一位教授站在那里。教授旁边有一位访客。访客原来是一位著名的风险投资家。对吧？教授转过身对你说：“哦，Joe，这位是某某某。他正在寻找有趣的项目进行投资。”这就是你的时刻了，对吧？
Wait, wait, wait, and you've actually seen this happen?
等等，等等，等等，你真的见过这种情况发生吗？
This happens literally every day in Cambridge, Massachusetts. There are probably 100 venture capitalist circling, looking for the next thing to invest in. And so it's these chance meetings, it happens regularly.
这在马萨诸塞州的剑桥确实每天都在发生。可能有100位风险投资家在这里徘徊，寻找下一个投资目标。所以这些偶遇是经常发生的。
The basics of a good elevator pitch, he says, are straightforward, talk in a way your grandparents could understand, don't expect the listener is an expert or knows scientific jargon. That's apparently a challenge for lots of engineers. You also have to explain how you and your team are qualified to actually accomplish the thing you're setting out to do. You have to prove you're an expert in field, if you've got Nobel Laureates working with you, it would be a good time to mention it. And finally, engage the listeners emotions. Grab them from the start.
他说，一个好的电梯演讲的基本要素很简单，用你祖父母都能听懂的方式说话，不要指望听众是专家或懂科学术语。显然这对许多工程师来说是个挑战。你还必须解释你和你的团队有什么资质来完成你准备做的事情。你必须证明你是该领域的专家，如果你有诺贝尔奖得主和你一起工作，那是提到的好时机。最后，调动听众的情绪。从一开始就抓住他们。
At the MIT competition, there was a pitch for medical procedure that Tim says, "Did that really well with a very simple gimmick". Here is the pitch. There was a space theme to the competition. So you'll hear each pitch begins with a countdown.
在麻省理工学院的比赛中，有一个医疗程序的推销，Tim说：“用一个非常简单的噱头做得非常好”。这是推销词。比赛有一个太空主题。所以你会听到每个推销都以倒计时开始。
Three, two, one.
三，二，一。
Take off!
起飞！
This year, Harrison Ford turned 67, putting him at a high risk for prostate cancer. If tomorrow he were to be sadly diagnosed with this disease, he would discover that he has two main treatment options, either undergo surgery to remove his prostate rendering him impotent, or do nothing but be comforted by having sex.
今年，Harrison Ford 67岁了，这使他患前列腺癌的风险很高。如果明天他不幸被诊断出患有这种疾病，他会发现他有两个主要的治疗选择，要么接受手术切除前列腺导致阳痿，要么什么都不做但至少还能保持性生活。
At Hydrangle Systems, we don't want the Indiana Joneses if the world to have to choose between life and sex. That is why our team of biomedical engineers at the Johns Hopkins University has designed and created the Apex. The Apex is a probe-like device that is used during minimally invasive freezing procedures to protect the sex nerves surrounding the prostate and maintain patient potency.
在Hydrangle Systems，我们不想让世界上的Indiana Jones们在生命和性之间做出选择。这就是为什么我们在约翰霍普金斯大学的生物医学工程师团队设计并创造了Apex。Apex是一种探头设备，用于微创冷冻手术中，以保护前列腺周围的性神经并维持患者的性能力。
Let me just pause this for a second. So I heard that, and I wondered how poor Harrison Ford get dragged into this pitch.
让我先暂停一下。所以我听到了这个，我想知道可怜的Harrison Ford是怎么被拖进这个推销里的。
Yeah, exactly. But if you took Harrison Ford out of it, it would lack that moment that causes you to set up and listen. Now I don't know that Harrison Ford ever had this procedure. I think it really has nothing to do with him. But it was a wonderful device. And really probably everyone in the room remembers that pitch a year later.
是的，完全正确。但如果你把Harrison Ford拿掉，它就缺少了那个让你坐直聆听的时刻。现在我不知道Harrison Ford是否做过这个手术。我认为这和他真的没关系。但这是一个很棒的设备。而且可能一年后房间里的每个人都还记得那个推销。
The prostate cancer treatment market is worth $3.4 billion. The Apex will start generating revenue at the end of year two, and is so transformative that the acquisition of Hydrangle Systems at any stage will allow for a quick return on investment. So men and women, don't let prostate cancer be your temple of doom, invest in Hydrangle Systems. And we'll let you stay as active as Indiana Jones.
前列腺癌治疗市场价值34亿美元。Apex将在第二年年底开始产生收入，而且它是如此具有变革性，以至于在任何阶段收购Hydrangle Systems都将带来快速的投资回报。所以男士们女士们，不要让前列腺癌成为你的“毁灭神殿”，投资Hydrangle Systems。我们将让你保持像Indiana Jones一样的活力。
There's more one more element that I really think is important in a pitch, and made the difference between the pitch you just heard, and the one that won that competition. And that is that what you're doing has to matter.
还有一个我认为在推销中非常重要的元素，也是刚才你听到的那个推销和赢得比赛的那个推销之间的区别。那就是你所做的事情必须要有意义。
Matter, you mean, like there's a lot of customers out there?
意义，你的意思是，有很多客户？
Well, no. That's good. Big makes money. That's important. That's mattering in one way. But I think there's so much going on in the world today, there's so many choices we have about what to spend our time on, that we tend to put a little extra energy into the ones where we say, this is a problem that really needs attention. Right? So I worry about Harrison Ford's sex life somewhat. That matters I suppose. But they're probably problems out there that matter more.
嗯，不。那很好。大的赚大钱。这很重要。这是其中一种意义。但我认为当今世界上发生的事情太多了，我们在时间花在哪里方面有很多选择，所以我们倾向于把更多的精力投入到那些我们认为“这是一个真正需要关注的问题”的事情上。对吧？所以我有点担心Harrison Ford的性生活。我想这有意义。但外面可能有更重要的问题。
Really so you're almost saying that people who invest in stuff want to make the world a better place as part of their investing, and that you have to take that into account.
真的吗？所以你几乎是说投资的人想让世界变得更好，作为他们投资的一部分，你必须考虑到这一点。
There are certainly investors who care only about the money. But I think that of the investors I know, they would prefer to have an investment which both makes money and does something exciting that makes the world a better place. That's probably why most of us who do investing got into that.
确实有只关心钱的投资者。但我认为在我认识的投资者中，他们更倾向于选择既能赚钱又能做一些令人兴奋的事情，让世界变得更好的投资。这可能就是我们这些做投资的人进入这个行业的原因。
Really? Didn't people get into investing to make money?
真的吗？人们进入投资行业不是为了赚钱吗？
I'm talking about the investors who invest in new ideas, the crazy new ideas, if you will. I think if you were just purely interesting in making money, you would probably end up on Wall Street. And if you are hunting around the halls of MIT, meeting with the head of the chemistry department, that kind of person is a little bit of a quirkier person, and in my experience, is someone who is more about the outcomes and not solely about the economics.
我说的是那些投资新点子、疯狂新点子的投资者。我认为如果你纯粹只是想赚钱，你可能会去华尔街。如果你在麻省理工学院的走廊里游荡，和化学系主任见面，那种人有点古怪，以我的经验，是更关注结果而不是只关注经济效益的人。
Well then let's play the winner. And let me ask you what is this person doing right. Let's hear the pitch
好吧，那我们来放一下获胜者的录音。让我问你这个人做对了什么。让我们听听这个推销。
Three,  two, one.
三，二，一。
Take off!
起飞！
The most widely used manufactured material on the planet is concrete. On average, each person uses more than three tons of concrete a year. Unfortunately concrete manufacturing process contributes to more than 10% of carbon dioxide emissions worldwide. However, they have been able to develop a concrete that not only cuts the carbon dioxide emissions by half, but also it is five times stronger than normal concrete.
地球上使用最广泛的制造材料是混凝土。平均每人每年使用超过三吨混凝土。不幸的是，混凝土制造过程占全球二氧化碳排放量的10%以上。然而，他们已经能够开发出一种混凝土，不仅将二氧化碳排放量减少了一半，而且强度是普通混凝土的五倍。
Our design is unique because we have discovered how to change the very nanostructure of concrete. This approach is environmentally friendly, and at the same time, it reduces the costs of concrete manufacturing by 40%. Given that the US market for concrete is over $100 billion a year, this makes--
我们的设计是独一无二的，因为我们发现了如何改变混凝土的纳米结构。这种方法既环保，又同时将混凝土制造的成本降低了40%。鉴于美国混凝土市场每年超过1000亿美元，这使得——
Actually, let me stop so far. So what have you heard so far that's working?
其实，让我暂停一下。到目前为止你听到了什么有用的东西？
OK, so it's just unbelievable. So first of all he's saying this is $100 billion market. So it's a lot of money. The greed gene, the greed glands are flowing here. Second of all, he's saying our product is cheaper than what's out there now. The single biggest motivator for a business, or anybody, to use a new product instead of the existing product, is because it's cheaper. So that's a quick way into the market. OK, so it's cheaper.
好的，这简直令人难以置信。首先他说这是一个1000亿美元的市场。所以钱很多。贪婪基因，贪婪腺体在这里流淌。其次，他说我们的产品比现在市场上的便宜。任何企业或任何人使用新产品而不是现有产品的最大动力，就是因为它更便宜。所以这是一个快速进入市场的方法。好的，所以它更便宜。
Second of all, if he said it's better but it's not cheaper, that's trickier, right? Well, do I need it better? So the first thing, it's cheaper. The second thing is it's also better. He said it's five times stronger than existing concrete. Wow. And then he gives you the it matters line. Right? He says that 10% of global production of carbon dioxide emissions is from concrete.
其次，如果他说它更好但并不便宜，那就比较棘手了，对吧？好吧，我需要它更好吗？所以第一件事，它更便宜。第二件事是它也更好。他说它比现有的混凝土强五倍。哇。然后他给你讲了那句“有意义”的话。对吧？他说全球10%的二氧化碳排放量来自于混凝土。
And then here he gets to the point where he has the qualifications of the people that they're a team who can actually pull this off.
然后他讲到了他的人员资质，他们是一个能真正完成这件事的团队。
We have a team of five researches, including three superstar professors at MIT. I, myself, am a last year Ph.D. student working on innovative concrete. And we are looking for two more passionate people to complete our team for financial aspects.
我们有一个由五名研究人员组成的团队，包括三位麻省理工学院的明星教授。我自己是一名从事创新混凝土研究的最后一年博士生。我们正在寻找另外两名充满热情的人来完成我们的财务团队。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Now you hear a lot of pitches. What are some of the weirdest pitches you've ever heard?
现在你听过很多推销。你听过最奇怪的推销是什么？
Well, this is actually very recent, in the last few weeks. And so I hope someone listening to this program is enthralled with this idea, and somehow finds the entrepreneur and invests in them. We didn't. But this entrepreneur probably has a number of dogs and has a backyard. And the question is what to do with all the dog remainders left in the backyard.
嗯，这其实是很近期的，在过去几周里。所以我希望听到这个节目的人对这个点子着迷，并以某种方式找到这位企业家并投资他们。我们没有。但这位企业家可能有几只狗，还有一个后院。问题是该怎么处理后院里剩下的狗狗排泄物。
And what they invented was a cup that you can put over the dog remainder. And it liquefies the poop so that it will flow into the ground, and I guess also fertilize the ground. And the way they describe doing it is that they have a series of high speed knives which move through the space underneath this cup, through the poop in every possible direction while-- I think, if I understood it correctly-- spraying the poop at high speed with water, something of the nature.
他们发明了一个杯子，你可以把它盖在狗狗排泄物上。它将粪便液化，使其流入地下，我想还能肥沃土地。他们描述这样做的方式是，在杯子下面有一系列高速移动的刀片，在粪便中朝各个方向移动，同时——我想，如果我理解正确的话——用水以高速喷射粪便，类似于那种东西。
Ew.
呃。
Well you say that, but if you have this problem, wouldn't you want to make the poop go away?
好吧，你这么说，但如果你有这个问题，难道你不想让粪便消失吗？
I don't know. There's just something so disgusting about that, about this device. Then you have to like clean out the poo-encrusted device afterward.
我不知道。这个设备本身就让人感觉非常恶心。而且之后你还得清理那个沾满粪便的设备。
Well, I think actually, the high speed water actually cleans it. So I think it cleans itself.
嗯，我想其实那个高速水流会自动清理它。所以我认为它会自动清洗。
Ah. So I don't know why, but it just seems really disgusting to me. Why didn't you invest in it?
啊。所以我不知道为什么，但它对我来说就是显得非常恶心。你为什么不投资它？
I think maybe that's one of the things, that it didn't seem like something that we wanted to bank our futures on. We'd probably have to go to conferences and demonstrate this on a regular basis or something.
我想也许这就是原因之一，它看起来不像是我们想把未来押在上面的东西。我们可能必须定期去参加会议并演示这个东西什么的。
Ira, the inventiveness of people in this country is just completely remarkable. I've lived all over the world and--
Ira，这个国家的创造力真是太了不起了。我住过世界各地，而且——
Wait, wait, I want to stay on the poo for a second. I feel like what you're saying is very uplifting. But I want to bring us back to poo. You know the problem with this, what you're saying, that's exactly the problem with this. If you got into business with these people, you'd be talking about poo all the time. Like your life would be filled with these poo discussions. And you'd be constantly having to evoke the image in your head of poo dissolving underneath this cup over and over. Like that image would be in your head like every day. You'd have to think about that. Like who wants to be in that business?
等等，等等，我想继续讨论粪便一会儿。我觉得你说的话非常振奋人心。但我还是想把我们带回粪便的话题。你知道这个问题的麻烦在于，你所说的话，这正是这个问题的麻烦所在。如果你和这些人一起做生意，你就会一直讨论粪便。你的生活就像被这些粪便讨论填满了。你必须不断地在脑海中想象粪便在这个杯子下溶解的样子，一次又一次。那种形象会每天都在你的脑海里。你必须考虑这个问题。谁想做那种生意？
Well you know, people are in the septic tank emptying business. Right? I mean these are businesses. Somebody has to take care of them. Why not this one?
嗯，你知道，有人在做化粪池清理工作，对吧？我的意思是这些都是生意。总得有人处理它们。为什么不是这个呢？
Tim Rowe, venture capitalist at the Cambridge Innovation Center.
Tim Rowe，剑桥创新中心的风险投资家。
[MUSIC - "SEXY PITCH" BY  MIT $100K ENTREPRENEURSHIP COMPETITION]
[音乐 - 麻省理工学院10万美元创业竞赛的《性感演讲》]
Act Two, The Invention of Cheese. We follow all these business pitches now with an anti-pitch from Kumail Nanjiani. It's very brief, not from the MIT competition, for a new product you may have heard of.
第二篇章，奶酪的发明。我们现在跟随所有这些商业推销，带来Kumail Nanjiani的“反推销”。这非常简短，不是来自麻省理工学院的比赛，而是关于你可能听说过的一种新产品。
Have you guys heard of this new drug called cheese, cheese? You've heard of it? No, OK. That's like the street name for it. It's like a new drug cocktail called cheese. And I read like four or five news reports on it that were like, "There's this new drug called cheese that's sweeping the nation. Kids in the Midwest are doing it. It's an epidemic. It's a new drug. It's an epidemic."
你们听说过这种叫“奶酪”的新药吗？奶酪？你们听说过吗？没有，好吧。那是它的“街头名称”。它就像一种叫“奶酪”的新毒品组合。我读了四五篇关于它的新闻报道，大意是：“有一种叫奶酪的新药正在席卷全国。中西部的孩子们正在使用它。这是一种流行病。这是一种新药。这是一种流行病。”
Then I looked up what cheese is, cheese is Tylenol PM and heroin. So really it's heroin. It's mostly heroin. Heroin's doing the heavy lifting in this drug cocktail. It's not a new drug. It's mostly heroin. I can't put heroin on pancakes and go, I have a new drug. I call it shake cakes. You eat them every day. If you stop, you'll get the shakes. Don't forget the special shake sauce, it's maple syrup and heroin. Pour that on there. It's not a new drug, is my point. It's mostly heroin.
然后我查了一下什么是奶酪，奶酪就是泰诺（Tylenol PM）加海洛因。所以实际上它就是海洛因。它主要是海洛因。海洛因在这次毒品组合中起到了主要作用。它不是一种新药。它主要是海洛因。我不能把海洛因放在煎饼上然后说，我有一种新药。我叫它“摇摆饼”。你每天吃。如果你停下来，你会颤抖。别忘了特殊的摇摆酱，它是枫糖浆和海洛因。倒在那上面。我的观点是，它不是一种新药。它主要是海洛因。
I think the last new drug was crystal meth, which you had to make in your bathtub. And if you [BLEEP] up while you were making it, everything would explode and you would die. That's how dangerous that drug is. Just trying to make it can kill you. And you make it just from shit you get at the store. To make cheese, you still need heroin. Just do the heroin. You already have heroine. Just do the heroin. That my message to you guys tonight. Just do the heroin. That's my time, guys. Thank you.
我想最后一种新药是水晶甲基苯丙胺，你得在浴缸里制作它。如果你制作的时候搞砸了，一切都会爆炸，你会死。这就是那种毒品有多危险。光是尝试制作它就能杀了你。而你只是用你在商店里买到的破玩意儿制作它。要制作“奶酪”，你仍然需要海洛因。直接用海洛因就行了。你已经有海洛因了。直接用海洛因就行了。这就是我今晚给你们的信息。直接用海洛因就行了。我的时间到了，伙计们。谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
OK, kids, say no to drugs. That's Kumail Nanjiani performing at Comix in New York. You can find his tour schedule on Twitter. He's headlining his first show at the Hollywood Improve August 17.
好吧，孩子们，向毒品说不。这是Kumail Nanjiani在纽约Comix的表演。你可以在Twitter上找到他的巡演时间表。他将于8月17日在好莱坞Improv进行他的首次专场演出。
Coming up, smoke your way to financial health That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，用吸烟的方式换取财务健康。这将在片刻后播出。来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续播出。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that team. Today's show, million dollar idea, stories of great ones, and less successful ones. We have arrived it act three of our show, Act Three, Get Rich or Die Trying. Chana Joffe-Walt has the story of our next million dollar idea, a very, very ambitious idea.
《美国生活》，我是Ira Glass。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“百万美元点子”，有关于伟大点子的故事，也有关于不那么成功点子的故事。我们已经到了节目的第三篇章，第三篇章，富起来或者在尝试中死去。Chana Joffe-Walt带来了我们下一个百万美元点子的故事，一个非常、非常雄心勃勃的点子。
This particular million dollar idea was to take something generally seen as bad and turn it good, death. I think it's safe to say, universally seen as a bad thing. So take that and make people see good in it. That was the plan.
这个特定的百万美元点子是将通常被视为坏事的东西变成好事，死亡。我想可以肯定地说，死亡被普遍视为坏事。所以利用这一点，让人们看到其中的好处。这就是计划。
It started in Prague in 1999. A couple law makers begin unwittingly laying the groundwork for a million dollar idea, by doing something tedious, something lawmakers always do, talking about the budget, specifically talking about raising taxes on cigarettes to cover that budget. Czech reporters then began doing something tedious reporters always do, randomly asking smokers on the street for their two cents.
它始于1999年的布拉格。几位立法者在不知不觉中开始为一个百万美元的点子奠定基础，他们做了一件乏味的事情，立法者总是做的事情，讨论预算，特别是讨论提高香烟税以覆盖预算。捷克记者随后开始做记者总是做的乏味事情，随机询问街上的吸烟者他们的看法。
On a busy Prague street, some shrugged saying at most, they would cut down, while others admitted once prices rose, they would consider quitting for good.
在繁忙的布拉格街道上，有些人耸耸肩说最多他们会减少吸烟量，而另一些人承认一旦价格上涨，他们会考虑彻底戒烟。
I guess I'm going to have to quit. What can you do? I'm a pension earner. And it really hits my pension check. I've already reduced the number I smoke to only ten a day.
我想我不得不戒烟。你能怎么办？我是领养老金的人。这真的会影响我的养老金支票。我已经把每天抽的数量减少到只有十支了。
Definitely it's a good thing. I'm for it. When the prices go up, it will force me to consider whether I really want to put my money into cigarettes instead of, for example, sport.
这绝对是件好事。我支持。当价格上涨时，它会迫使我考虑我是否真的想把钱花在香烟上，而不是花在比如体育运动上。
You know whose dog whistles that only dogs can here, this kind of man on the street news clip where people are casually throwing around the words quit, and put money somewhere else, is a tobacco executives dog whistle. They pay attention immediately. And that attention is undivided.
你知道只有狗能听到的那种狗哨吗？这种街头新闻片段里，人们随意抛出“戒烟”、“把钱花在别处”这些词，就是烟草高管的狗哨。他们会立即注意。而且那种注意力是全神贯注的。
Those smokers in 1999 more than likely smoked Phillip Morris cigarettes. The company was the largest manufacturer in the Czech Republic by far, and the largest in the world. And there was something specific about the Czech taxes conversation that got under the skin of Phillip Morris executives. It was this. Legislators were arguing that tax increases were necessary because smoking hurt the economy. People get sick from smoking. And in a place like the Czech Republic with public health care, the government has to pay for that.
1999年的那些吸烟者很可能吸的是菲利普莫里斯（Philip Morris）香烟。该公司是捷克共和国遥遥领先的最大制造商，也是世界上最大的制造商。捷克的税收谈话中有些具体的事情触动了菲利普莫里斯高管的神经。就是这个。立法者辩称提高税收是必要的，因为吸烟损害经济。人们因吸烟而生病。而在像捷克共和国这样拥有公共医疗保健的国家，政府必须为此买单。
This particular logic struck the Phillip Morris people as bizarre. Not just bizarre, wrong. And so inspired by accuracy and the threat of taxes, Phillip Morris came up with their million dollar idea.
这种特殊的逻辑让菲利普莫里斯的人感到离奇。不仅仅是离奇，而且是错误的。因此，受到准确性和税收威胁的启发，菲利普莫里斯想出了他们的百万美元点子。
Well, they commissioned a study to tote up the costs and the benefits to the Czech government of its people's smoking habits. Gordan Fairclough covered tobacco for the Wall Street Journal. And he says, "In its simplest form, the idea was this, death, death saves you money, the more complicated form, a 28 page economic analysis.
嗯，他们委托了一项研究，来计算捷克政府国民吸烟习惯的成本和收益。《华尔街日报》报道烟草行业的Gordan Fairclough说：“最简单的形式，这个点子的核心是：死亡，死亡能为你省钱。”更复杂的形式是一份28页的经济分析报告。
Could you just read the executive summary of that study, just the bolded part?
你能读一下那份研究的执行摘要吗，就读加粗的部分？
The bolded part, OK. So the beginning of the study says, "Based on up to date reliable data and consideration of all relevant contributing factors, the effect of smoking on the public finance balance in the Czech Republic in 1999 was positive, estimated at CZK 5.8 billion.
加粗的部分，好的。研究开头说：“基于最新的可靠数据和对所有相关因素的考量，1999年吸烟对捷克共和国公共财政平衡的影响是正面的，估计为58亿捷克克朗。”
Quick currency conversion interruption, CZK 5.8 billion in 2000, that's after $147 million a year, coming largely from tobacco-related taxes, but also from other things.
快速货币换算中断，2000年的58亿捷克克朗，大约相当于1.47亿美元，主要来自烟草相关税收，但也来自其他方面。
So basically, you know, what they're trying to do here is tote up here the gains and losses to public finances from smoking. So if you have people smoking and their life span is not as long, you record big savings on housing for the elderly, for example, [INTERPOSING VOICES].
所以基本上，你知道，他们在这里试图做的是统计吸烟对公共财政的收益和损失。所以如果人们吸烟，寿命不那么长，你就会记录下为老年人提供住房的大笔节省，例如，[重叠的声音]。
Because people die?
因为人们死了？
Because people die. Because people die early, you also pay less out in pensions and other social benefits to the elderly. People die early, you don't have to pay health care costs for all their non-smoking-related illnesses that they would get later in life, all of which in this study are seen on that kind of positive side of the ledger.
因为人们死了。因为人们早死，你在养老金和其他社会福利上支付给老人的钱也就少了。人们早死，你就不必为他们生命后期可能患上的所有非吸烟相关疾病支付医疗费用，所有这些在研究中都被视为账目的正面。
On the negative side, you have the costs of fires started by people smoking, falling asleep in bed smoking, doing other things with cigarettes. The financial implications of people who stop working earlier, either because they die or they get too sick to work, so the state then loses the income tax that they might charge those people. Also on the cost side is, the cost of treating people for smoking-related diseases and for secondhand smoke.
在负面方面，你有因吸烟、在床上吸烟睡着、用香烟做其他事情引起火灾的成本。因为人们早死或太虚弱而无法工作，国家就会失去可能向这些人征收的所得税，这方面的财务影响也在负面。同样在成本方面的是，治疗人们的吸烟相关疾病和二手烟的成本。
So the way these consultants tote that all up is people smoking is a net benefit, a net financial benefit to the Czech state of that CZK 5.8 billion.
所以顾问们统计这一切的方式是，吸烟对捷克政府来说是一个净收益，是一个价值58亿捷克克朗的净财务收益。
The report is thorough. It begins by laying out its methodology, then later its quantification methods, concluding with a glossary that defines morbidity and mortality. Turns out-- who knew-- the technically uses of those two words are very different. And then five pages of references. Gordan Fairclough and I spent a long time reading through it together.
这份报告很详尽。它首先列出了方法论，然后是量化方法，最后以定义发病率和死亡率的词汇表结尾。事实证明——谁知道呢——这两个词的技术用法非常不同。然后还有五页的参考文献。Gordan Fairclough和我花了很多时间一起阅读它。
So you don't have  to pay that. You don't have to pay the monthly insurance payments paid from the state budget for each pensioner, each retired person. Then you multiply that out by the 22,000 deaths due to tobacco smoking in the Czech Republic in 1999 with a nice reference to an epidemiology, one of the most famous of the tobacco controlled epidemiologists there.
所以你不必支付那个。你不必支付从国家预算中为每个养老金领取者，每个退休人员支付的每月保险金。然后你用这个乘以1999年捷克共和国因吸烟导致的22,000例死亡，并附带了流行病学方面的漂亮参考，那是那里最著名的烟草控制流行病学家之一。
So this is a weird thing. To get all these numbers to make their argument, Phillip Morris had to go to the only people who collect these numbers, their enemies, public health people, tobacco control lobbyists, basically anti-tobacco people.
所以这是一件奇怪的事情。为了得到所有这些数字来支持他们的观点，菲利普莫里斯必须去寻找唯一收集这些数字的人，他们的敌人，公共卫生人员，烟草控制游说者，基本上就是反烟草人士。
You know what the tobacco control people would tote up as the harm of smoking, and Phillip Morris is toting up as the benefit to the Czech state.
你知道烟草控制人员会把吸烟的危害加起来，而菲利普莫里斯却把它加起来作为捷克政府的收益。
I read the report and couldn't believe that they had put it in writing.
我读了这份报告，简直不敢相信他们竟然把它写成了书面文件。
This is one of the tobacco control people, Matt Myers. He works for the Campaign for Tobacco Free Kids in D.C. In the years leading up to the Phillip Morris study, Matt and a lot of other anti-tobacco people had done some research that told them to ease up on the smoking is bad for you message, and instead, focus on a message that seemed like it would be a lot more effective. Tobacco companies are bastards and they're out to get you.
这是烟草控制人员之一，Matt Myers。他在华盛顿为“无烟草青少年运动”工作。在菲利普莫里斯研究出炉前的几年里，Matt和其他许多反烟草人士做了一些研究，告诉他们减轻“吸烟有害健康”的信息，转而专注于一个看起来效率高得多的信息。烟草公司是混蛋，他们想害你。
For us, a report like this was truly like manna from heaven. This report was a complete gift. The next thing I did was sit down with our communications people and say what can we do with this?
对我们来说，这样的报告简直就像天赐之物。这份报告完全是一份礼物。我做的下一件事就是和我们的公关人员坐下来谈论我们能用它做什么？
The story ran in the Prague Post. Gordan wrote it up for the Wall Street Journal. It then quickly made it to CBS Evening News, ABC World News Tonight, in New York Times, and USA Today among many others. Some select newspaper headlines, "Death in the Ashes", "Tobacco Blows its Smoke" and "Smoking Cuts Elderly Costs and Elderly". Matt Myers and several other tobacco people ran there own ran their own ad campaign featuring a corpse at the morgue with a price tag dangling off a grey, big toe.
这个故事在《布拉格邮报》上刊登了。Gordan为《华尔街日报》写了它。随后它很快传到了CBS晚间新闻、ABC世界新闻、纽约时报和今日美国等媒体。一些精选的报纸头条包括，“灰烬中的死亡”、“烟草吹出的烟雾”和“吸烟减少了老年人的成本和老年人”。Matt Myers和其他几位反烟草人士发起了他们自己的广告活动，展示了一具停尸房里的尸体，一个大脚趾上挂着标价牌。
Let me put it this one, in one fell swoop, it allowed us to counter over $100 million of tobacco advertising. And that felt good.
让我这样说，它一举让我们抵消了超过1亿美元的烟草广告宣传。这感觉很好。
Is was worth $100 million?
它价值1亿美元吗？
Yes in critical respects. Getting our hands on that report allowed us to do with almost no funds, what the tobacco industry had spend $100 million trying to do.
是的，在关键方面。得到这份报告让我们几乎不花什么资金，就做到了烟草行业花1亿美元试图做到的事情。
Phillip Morris apologized, then apologized again. Top executives repeated that they never authorized the study, that it was done by a Czech subsidiary of Phillip Morris without headquarter's permission. They issued public statements such as, "All of us at Philip Morris are extremely sorry. No one benefits from the very real, serious, and significant diseases caused by smoking".
菲利普莫里斯道歉了，然后又道歉了。高管们重申他们从未授权这项研究，它是菲利普莫里斯的捷克子公司在未经总部许可的情况下完成的。他们发表了公开声明，例如：“我们菲利普莫里斯的所有人都感到非常抱歉。吸烟引起的真实、严重且重大的疾病对任何人都没有好处。”
And their public relations guy in Prague, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] did one recorded interview, one poorly recorded interview with Czech Radio.
而他们在布拉格的公关人员[听不清]在捷克电台做了一次录音采访，一次录音质量很差的采访。
We commissioned this study and it was not about health policy. But it was a part of an ongoing debate about the economics of cigarette excise tax policy in the Czech Republic. And I must say Phillip Morris deeply regrets any impression from this study that a premature death of smokers represents a benefit to this society.
我们委托了这项研究，它与卫生政策无关。它是捷克共和国烟草消费税政策经济学争论的一部分。我必须说，菲利普莫里斯对这项研究可能产生的“吸烟者早死对社会有利”的印象深表遗憾。
I talked with several Phillip Morris people from that time. Not one and them would allow me to record. So here's what I learned, In the midst of the media disaster, Phillip Morris set out to make sure this kind of thing never happen again. The company called a meeting in Switzerland, all the bosses from around the world came in, about 15 men, maybe a women or two were there. No one quite remembers.
我和当时菲利普莫里斯的几个人谈过。没有一个人允许我录音。所以我了解到的是，在媒体灾难中，菲利普莫里斯设法确保这种事情永远不会再发生。公司在瑞士召开了一次会议，来自世界各地的老板都来了，大约15个男人，也许有一两个女人在那里。没人记得很清楚。
And at that meeting, the guys from headquarters announced to the room, "You are not to talk about the death benefit, not in your reports, not in public, not ever again. We are not doing this anymore".
在那个会议上，总部的人向房间宣布：“你们不准谈论死亡收益，在你们的报告中不准谈，在公共场合不准谈，永远不要再谈。我们不再这样做这种事了。”
The group listened to this for awhile. And then a single hand rose. "Excuse me, but they were the ones saying smoking costs the government more than it saves. Are we supposed to just let him lie?" Then there were more hands. "Yeah, what do you mean"? More than one person piped up with, "You're asking us to argue with one arm tied behind our back". And most popular of all in that room on that day, "But it's true. What we're saying is true. Early death does save society money".
这群人听了一会儿。然后一只手举了起来。“抱歉，但正是他们说吸烟对政府的成本大于收益。我们难道就该让他们撒谎吗？”然后有更多举手。“是的，你是什么意思？”不止一个人插嘴说：“你这是要求我们自断一臂地去争论。”那天在房间里最受欢迎的话是：“但这是事实。我们所说的是真的。早死确实为社会省钱。”
Gordan Fairclough, a reporter with the Wall Street Journal would go to Phillip Morris headquarters during this time for interviews. And he says people really did seem incredulous at the negative response.
《华尔街日报》的记者Gordan Fairclough在此期间前往菲利普莫里斯总部进行采访。他说人们看起来确实对负面反应感到难以置信。
I think they become kind of hardened to this. There's a certain psychological distancing that goes on by tobacco executives, doing that work and selling this product knowing that it is, in fact, addictive, and knowing that it has such serious health consequences. And I think that some of that allows you to look at a report like this and not think to the average member of the general public this is going to seem incredibly callous.
我认为他们对这种事变得麻木了。烟草高管进行着一种心理疏离，做着那种工作，销售这种产品，明知它实际上是成瘾的，明知它有如此严重的健康后果。我认为其中一些让你能够看着像这样的报告，而不去想对于普通公众来说，这看起来会是多么冷酷无情。
It must be so strange for them too because there was such a long period of time where they were denying that smoking killed people. And now finally they're saying we're acknowledging it. We're writing the death benefit into our equations and you guys are still giving us crap.
对他们来说肯定也很奇怪，因为有很长一段时间他们在否认吸烟会导致人们死亡。现在他们终于承认了。我们在我们的方程式中写下了“死亡收益”，你们这些家伙还在给我们找麻烦。
That's true. They must have thought that was fairly ironic that, in fact, here they are admitting that this will end everyone's life earlier, and then they get slammed for it.
那是真的。他们肯定认为这很讽刺，事实上，他们在这里承认这会缩短每个人的生命，然后他们却因此被猛烈抨击。
But after that, the tobacco people shut up about the death benefit, they fell in line, and they never publicly mentioned it again. The anti-tobacco people, though kind of won't let this go. They could have called attention to the study, declared outrage, mocked it, all of which they did do. And then they could have named the whole incident a success and walked away, which weirdly they did not do.
但那之后，烟草界的人关于死亡收益闭嘴了，他们保持一致，再也没有公开提及。然而反烟草人士有点不依不饶。他们本可以引起对这项研究的注意，宣布愤怒，嘲笑它，所有这些他们都做了。然后他们本可以宣布整个事件是胜利并走开，这奇怪的是他们没有这样做。
Instead anti-tobacco people have spent the last decade trying to prove that the data, not just the moral question of counting deaths on the plus side of an economic analysis, but the actual data Phillip Morris is using was wrong, which when it comes to this study, seems a little bit besides the point. Doesn't it?
相反，反烟草人士在过去十年里一直在努力证明数据是错误的，不仅仅是计算经济分析中死亡人数的道德问题，而是菲利普莫里斯使用的实际数据是错误的。这对于这项研究来说，似乎有点偏离重点了，不是吗？
These guys clearly won this round, clear victory for tobacco control people, battle won. But they won't drop it. Instead, Matt Myers, with the Campaign for Tobacco Free Kids, has been doing his own studies about whether or not smokers save the government money. And his number show they do not.
这些人显然赢了这一轮，反烟草人士取得了明显的胜利，战斗获胜。但他们不愿放弃。相反，Matt Myers和“无烟草青少年运动”一直在做他们自己的研究，关于吸烟者是否为政府省钱。而他的数字显示并没有。
What we thought the data showed, and what it turned out that the data showed, was that tobacco was an enormous net drain on the economy. I think the numbers are very wrong.
我们认为数据表明的是，数据最后表明，烟草对经济造成了巨大的净消耗。我认为那些数字是非常错误的。
But it seems like part of the power of your position here is that you get to say look at those guys measuring the value of your death and the benefit of your death, that's ridiculous. And that's it. But then you are too. You're also doing your own economic analysis.
但似乎你这个职位的力量部分在于你可以说“看看那些测量你死亡价值和你死亡收益的家伙，那太荒谬了”。就是这样。但后来你也是如此。你也在做你自己的经济分析。
We're very clear. Efforts to reduce tobacco use have nothing to do with economic costs. They have everything to do with quality of life.
我们非常清楚。减少烟草使用的努力与经济成本无关。它们完全与生活质量有关。
But you are doing economic analyses. You're doing cost-benefit studies yourself.
但你在做经济分析。你自己就在做成本效益研究。
We did not start out making that argument. The public health community began to look at the economic issues only because the tobacco industry argued that as a society, we couldn't afford to reduce tobacco use. We have to respond to the tobacco industry's argument.
我们一开始并没有提出那个论点。公共卫生界开始关注经济问题，仅仅是因为烟草行业声称作为一个社会，我们负担不起减少烟草使用。我们必须回应烟草行业的论点。
In other words, they started it. And now it is on. So here we go, were they right? Does the fact that smokers die early mean that they save the rest of as money? Now Phillip Morris is obviously not the place you would go for an answer to that question. But luckily it is a question economists ask all the time about smoking and alcoholic obesity.
换句话说，是他们先挑起的。现在已经开打了。所以我们开始吧，他们对了吗？吸烟者早死意味着他们为我们其他人省钱了吗？现在菲利普莫里斯显然不是你去寻找那个问题答案的地方。但幸运的是，这是一个经济学家一直在询问关于吸烟、酗酒和肥胖的问题。
And the way they do it is they go through all the costs to society. Payment for lung cancer treatment, that means everyone's insurance rates go up, more sic days. Subtract the savings to society, pensions aren't paid out plus spent on nursing home care because people die sooner. And they total it all up. And eventually most economists come to this unsatisfying conclusion. It about evens out. Smokers probably cost society a little bit more than they save by dying early, but only a little. And they more than make up for that cost by paying taxes on their smoke.
他们这样做的方法是浏览社会的所有成本。支付肺癌治疗费用，这意味着每个人的保险费率都上涨，更多的病假。减去对社会的节省，因为人们死得早，养老金不支付，加上在疗养院护理上的花费也减少了。他们统计这一切。最终大多数经济学家得出了这个令人不满的结论。这大约抵消了。吸烟者通过早死可能比他们省下的钱多花社会一点钱，但只是多一点。而他们通过支付香烟税弥补了那部分成本。
People like Matt Myers have one mean beef with this approach. It doesn't count the cost to the smoker. The fact that the smoker will probably lose four years of his life, it doesn't count that. Tobacco control people want to contact that. They do count that. And when they do, they come to the conclusion tobacco costs society greatly, a conclusion they talk about in advertising and lobbying all the time now.
像Matt Myers这样的人对这种方法有一个主要的意见。它没有计算吸烟者的成本。吸烟者可能会损失四年生命的事实，它没有计算那个。烟草控制人员想要计算那个。他们确实计算了那个。当他们计算时，他们得出了烟草给社会造成了巨大成本的结论，这个结论他们现在一直在广告和游说中谈论。
And on the other side, Phillip Morris is completely quiet on this front. They don't point out that the majority of economists don't agree with that conclusion. They don't publish their own counter studies. And they don't talk about the death benefit, at least not publicly. They are quiet and watch their million dollar idea continue to live, just not on their side of the balance sheet.
而在另一边，菲利普莫里斯在这方面完全安静。他们没有指出大多数经济学家不同意那个结论。他们没有发布他们自己的反向研究。他们也没有谈论死亡收益，至少不在公开场合。他们保持安静，看着他们的百万美元点子继续存在，只是不在他们的资产负债表那一侧。
NPR's Chana Joffe-Walt is part of the Planet Money team. Planet Money is a co-production of NPR News and our radio show. They bring you economic stories that are not boring on their blog and their free twice-weekly podcast at npr.org/money.
NPR的Chana Joffe-Walt是“Planet Money”团队的一员。《Planet Money》是NPR新闻和我们广播节目的联合制作。他们在他们的博客和免费的每周两次的播客npr.org/money上为你带来不枯燥的经济故事。
[MUSIC - "WINNERS NEVER QUIT" BY PEDRO THE LION]
[音乐 - Pedro The Lion的《Winners Never Quit》]
Act Four, Don't hate the player. Somehow we've gotten this far into the show without anybody trying to make a fortune with an old fashioned scam, or out betting the casino, or beating the odds in some impossible way. Well let's correct that right this second with the story from Shawn Allee.
第四篇章，别恨玩家。不知怎么的，我们在这个节目里走了这么远，居然没有人试图通过老式的骗局、或者打败赌场、或者以某种不可能的方式胜出而发大财。好吧，让我们现在就用Shawn Allee的故事纠正一下。
In 1984, Michael Larson appeared on a CBS game show called Press Your Luck. He was just kind of contestant producers liked. He wore a simple grey suit, nothing flashing, and he had this aw shucks kind of smile like some guy from Ohio, when he was.
1984年，Michael Larson参加了CBS的一个游戏节目，叫《Press Your Luck》。他只是那种节目制作人喜欢的选手。他穿着简单的灰西装，没什么花哨的，他有着那种来自俄亥俄州的“哎呀抱歉”式的微笑，而他也确实来自那里。
Let's meet our second player, Michael Larson. How are you, Michael? Not Michael, what do you do for a living?
让我们见见我们的第二位选手，Michael Larson。你好吗，Michael？不是Michael，你以什么为生？
Oh, I drive an ice cream truck in the summer. I hope to win enough money here not to do that this summer.
哦，我夏天开冰淇淋车。我希望在这里赢足够的钱，这样夏天就不必那样做了。
Do you have it with you today?
你今天带它来了吗？
What producers that day didn't know, is that Michael Larson had come on to Press Your Luck with a plan, a kind of far-fetched plan, a take 'em to the cleaners, a plan that was months in the making, a plan to get rich in half an hour.
那天制作人不知道的是，Michael Larson带着一个计划来到了《Press Your Luck》，一个有点牵强的计划，一个“把他们清理干净”的计划，一个酝酿了几个月的计划，一个在半小时内发财的计划。
$56,851 and he's going again.
56,851美元，他还要继续。
Stop
停。
Stop at $5,000.
停在5000美元。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
All his life, Michael was always running some little scam or another. Now Michael died in 1999. So you're not going to hear about any this from him. But I talked to his brother, James. Michael was the youngest of four boys. James was the oldest. James says even in middle school, Michael got caught smuggling candy bars into class and jacking the prices way above retail.
他这一生，Michael总是搞些这样那样的骗局。Michael死于1999年。所以你不会从他那里听到这些。但我跟他弟弟James聊过。Michael是四个男孩中最小的。James是老大。James说即使在中学，Michael就被发现把糖果偷偷带进教室，并把价格抬高到零售价以上。
And James says after high school, though Michael was smart enough to go to college, he spent his time looking for easy ways to score.
James说高中毕业后，虽然Michael聪明得足以去上大学，但他把时间花在寻找赚钱的捷径上。
He didn't understand the value of good, honest hard work, and just go, and work, and do your job, and get your pay. He thought those people were fools.
他不懂那种诚实劳动、工作、做好本职工作并拿到报酬的价值。他认为那些人是傻瓜。
Michael's schemes ran the gamut. He started a business under a family member's name and then hired himself as an employee. Then he laid himself off to collect unemployment benefits. He'd watch for banks that would give you $500 for opening an account. He'd open one and wait the minimum time to collect the $500. Then he'd withdraw the money and do it again under a different name.
Michael的计划五花八门。他以家人的名义开了一家公司，然后雇佣自己为员工。然后他解雇了自己以领取失业救济金。他会留意那些开户就送500美元的银行。他会开一个，等待领取500美元的最短时间。然后他会取走钱，用另一个名字再做一次。
His house was filled with stacks of newspapers everywhere, and boxes, and piles, which he'd scour for possible scams. He never threw anything out. He might need them something, he'd say.
他的房子里到处堆满了报纸、盒子和杂物，他会为了可能的骗局搜寻这些。他从不扔掉任何东西。他可能会需要它们，他会说。
He used to sit at night and watch the TV and tape all these shows that you see on late night TV. You can make thousands of dollars by doing this or doing that. And he bought into that very much so.
他过去常坐在晚上看电视，录下所有你在深夜电视上看到的节目。通过做这个或做那个，你可以赚几千美元。他非常相信这一点。
He had a TV in the bathroom. He had one in the bedroom. He had one in the kitchen. He would just carry them in.
他在浴室里有一台电视。他在卧室里有一台。他在厨房里有一台。他会把它们搬进去。
This is Michael's former common law wife, Teresa Bertram .
这是Michael的前事实婚姻伴侣Teresa Bertram。
He had like 12 in the living room lined up on the walls. They were the old consoles. And he would have one sitting on top of it and the other one sitting on top. And we had an entire wall full of 19 inch, 25 inch televisions. And he would watch them all at once. It got so hot back here it peeled the paint off the wall.
他客厅的墙上排着12台电视。那是老式的控制台电视。他会在上面放一台，又在上面放另一台。我们整面墙全是19英寸、25英寸的电视。他会同时看它们。后面变得非常热，墙上的油漆都剥落了。
Teresa says she had a tough time explaining this TV business to visitors. Usually she'd just tell people Michael was straight up crazy. But Teresa says he was actually methodical with his TV viewing. He'd tune each TV to a different channel. The idea was to watch for anything that would make him rich. He's also watch TV ads, infomercials, and of course, game shows.
Teresa说她很难向访客解释这事。通常她只会告诉人们Michael疯了。但Teresa说他在看电视方面其实很有方法。他会把每台电视调到不同的频道。点子是寻找任何能让他发财的东西。他还看电视广告、信息购物节目，当然还有游戏节目。
He was intrigued with the game shows. And he wanted to find one that he could do.
他对游戏节目很感兴趣。他想找一个他能参与的。
Michael was convinced that someone smart could find loopholes in game shows that average people missed. So he'd videotape them all day and play them back in the evening. Teresa says sometimes he'd stay up all night fast-forwarding, rewinding, pausing, and re-watching, especially Press Your Luck.
Michael确信聪明人可以在游戏节目中找到普通人错过的漏洞。所以他整天录像，晚上回放。Teresa说有时他会整晚熬夜，快进、倒带、暂停，然后重看，尤其是《Press Your Luck》。
I remember I was in the kitchen and he yelled for me to come into the living room. And he was real happy and excited. And he said, I've got it. I've figured it out.
我记得那时我在厨房，他大喊让我去客厅。他非常开心和兴奋。他说，我抓住了。我弄明白了。
To understand what Michael was so excited about, you have to understand how Press Your Luck worked. If you don't know the show or remember it, maybe you've heard its catch phrase, big bucks, big bucks, no whammies.
要理解Michael为什么这么兴奋，你必须了解《Press Your Luck》是如何工作的。如果你不知道这个节目或不记得它，也许你听过它的口号：“Big bucks, big bucks, no whammies.”（大奖大奖，没踩雷）。
Three contestants would take turns at the show's big game board. It was like a huge Monopoly board with squares around the edge. When a player took a turn, a light would bounce all over from square to square in no particular order, until a player would press a big red button and the light would stop. If they were lucky, the square they landed on would have a prize like a vacation trip or money. But if they weren't lucky, they'd hit a whammy. And they'd lost all the prizes, the money, everything.
三名选手轮流操作节目的大型游戏板。它就像一个巨大的“大富翁”游戏板，四周都有方块。当玩家轮到时，灯光会在方块之间无序跳动，直到玩家按下大红按钮，灯光就会停止。如果幸运的话，他们停下的方块会有奖品，比如度假旅行或钱。但如果不幸运的话，他们会踩到“雷”（Whammy）。他们就会失去所有奖品、钱，一切。
All of the sounds simple enough. But here's the thing. To you, to me, and to the rest of America, the light on the Press Your Luck game board moved randomly. Michael knew we were wrong. Michael figured out that really there was nothing random about that game board. The light always moved in one of five patterns.
听起来很简单。但事情是这样的。对你，对我，和对其他美国人来说，游戏板上的灯光移动是随机的。Michael知道我们错了。Michael算出游戏板上其实没什么随机的。灯光总是遵循五种模式之一。
He was memorizing the patterns. He wrote some stuff down. He took little notes. And then he started doing the VCR and hitting the pause button. He would show me in here because he got really excited then. Watch this. I can stop it every time where I want to.
他记住了这些模式。他写下了一些东西。他记了点小笔记。然后他开始用录像机，按下暂停键。他会在里面给我展示，因为那时他真的非常兴奋。看这个。我可以每次都在我想要的地方停下来。
Michael spent months learning to push his VCR pause button at just the right moment, always on a prize, never on a whammy. Again, here's his brother, James.
Michael花了几个月时间学习在准确的时机按下录像机暂停键，总是停在奖品上，从不踩雷。再说一次，这是他弟弟James。
When Michael told me he was going to go to California, I didn't think he'd had a chance. I thought he'd get out there and find that it's not as easy as you think it is. And so I said good luck. But don't call me for bus money to get back.
当Michael告诉我他要去加州时，我不认为他有机会。我以为他到了那里会发现这并不像你想象的那么容易。所以我说祝好运。但别打电话给我要公交车费回来。
Which brings us back to the show.
这把我们带回了节目。
Michael Larson. How are you, Michael? Now Michael, what do you do for a living?
Michael Larson。你好吗，Michael？不是Michael，你以什么为生？
Oh, I drive an ice cream truck in the summer.
哦，我夏天开冰淇淋车。
Michael took his seat on Press Your Luck on May 19, 1984. Watching the tape, his grey hair is slicked back receding a bit. His beard is halfway to grey. He looks nervous.
Michael在1984年5月19日坐上了《Press Your Luck》的席位。看着录像，他的灰发向后梳，发际线有点退后。他的胡子花白了一半。他看起来很紧张。
Well, Michael, you want to earn enough money so you don't have to deal with your ice cream truck. You just want to eat the ice cream though.
嗯，Michael，你想赚足够的钱，这样就不必应付你的冰淇淋车了。你只是想吃冰淇淋对吧？
No, I've done enough of that, too.
不，那我也吃够了。
You've kind of OD'ed on ice cream, right? Well hopefully you won't OD on money, Michael.
你吃冰淇淋吃得过量了，对吧？希望你不会因为钱过量，Michael。
It was for me a very, very routine day.
对我来说，这是非常、非常平常的一天。
Darlene Lieblich Tipton was in the control room with the director and producers. Her job was to monitor the game and make sure everything was fair and square.
Darlene Lieblich Tipton在控制室和导演、制片人在一起。她的工作是监控游戏，确保一切公平合理。
I am looking at the same monitor that the director is looking at. So I see all the camera angles, all the shots. It's actually the best seat in the house.
我在看导演正在看的同一个监视器。所以我看到了所有的摄像角度，所有的镜头。这实际上是全场最好的座位。
Darlene says at first, Michael Larson didn't look like much.
Darlene说起初，Michael Larson看起来并不怎么样。
I'm going, stop.
我要说，停。
He got a whammy.
他中雷了。
Right here, after getting a whammy on his first spin, Michael shakes. his head, grits his teeth, and forces a smile. He looks unsure of himself. On his next turn, he concentrates before hitting the red button, and lands on $4,000 dollars and extra turn. Sure he smiles. But more than anything, he looks relieved.
就在这里，在他的第一次旋转中踩雷后，Michael摇了摇头，咬牙切齿，挤出一丝笑容。他看起来对自己没有信心。在他的下一次旋转时，他在按下红色按钮前进行了专注，停在4000美元和额外旋转上。当然，他笑了。但比起其他，他看起来更像是松了一口气。
After that he gets more confident. Turn after turn, he wracks up more and more money. By 18 grand, he reels back in his chair. At 21 grand, he waves his fists above his head. By 28 grand, Michael is literally bouncing in his seat. He's on a roll. And Michael, the host, the audience, everybody, they're all getting into it.
在那之后，他变得更自信了。轮次过后，他赢了越来越多的钱。到1万8时，他向后倒在椅子上。到2万1时，他在头上挥舞拳头。到2万8时，Michael在座位上蹦蹦跳跳。他势不可挡。Michael、主持人、观众，每个人，他们都被带动起来了。
It wasn't unusual for contestants to go on streaks. It was kind of the way the game was designed. After about, oh, I don't know, five to ten spins of the board, that's when it started to become obviously to people that he was hitting the same prize in the same square just about every time. And that skill, that's not random, and it's not luck.
选手出现连续获胜的情况并不罕见。这是游戏设计的方式。在大约，哦，我不知道，五到十次转板后，人们开始明显感觉到他几乎每次都停在同一个方块的同一个奖品上。那种技巧，那不是随机的，也不是运气的。
Stop.
停。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
He could aim and hit, which we didn't think was possible. And he continued to do it. Nobody else had ever done it that way. Everybody else had played it virtually like a slot machine. You just hit the button and it stops where it stops. He had it down to a skill, a fine art.
他可以瞄准并击中，这是我们认为不可能的。而且他继续这样做。以前没有人那样做过。每个人都是把它当作老虎机来玩的。你只是按下按钮，它在它停的地方停下。他把它练成了一种技巧，一种精湛的艺术。
Stop.
停。
at $4,000 and a spin.
停在4000美元和一个旋转上。
I've been in the booth for thousands of episodes of game shows, never one like that. First the booth got very quiet. And then there was an oh my god, oh my god, oh my god. It was what do we do? What do we do? People were turning to me saying can we stop this?
我在演播室看过成千上万集游戏节目，从没见过像那样的。首先演播室变得非常安静。然后是一阵“我的天，我的天，我的天”。当时就是我们该怎么办？我们该怎么办？人们转向我说，我们能停止这个吗？
He wasn't breaking any of the rules of the game. I could not stop the game. He was playing it according to the rules set out. We had no rule against what he was doing. He beat us at it. We have to let it play out the way it plays out and see what happens.
他没有违反游戏的任何规则。我不能停止游戏。他是按照设定的规则在玩。我们没有针对他所做的事情的规则。他在这一点上打败了我们。我们必须让它按它自己的方式进行，看看会发生什么。
Stop.
停。
$5,000 and a spin.
5000美元和一个旋转。
Michael's streak had gone so long that he busted the show's half hour format. The host did an impromptu interview to add time so the episode could be stretched into an hour-long special. (SUBJECT) GAME SHOW HOST: What are you going to do with the money, Michael?
Michael的连胜持续太久了，以至于打破了节目的半小时格式。主持人进行了一次即兴采访以增加时间，这样这一集可以被拉长成一小时的特别节目。（游戏节目主持人：你打算怎么用这笔钱，Michael？）
Invest in houses.
投资房子。
Real estate.
房地产。
Yes, real estate.
是的，房地产。
And not drive an ice cream truck.
而且不用开冰淇淋车。
That's right.
没错。
By the end of the show, Michael Larson had won a total of $110,237. Michael had shattered records that day, and not just for Press Your Luck, but for any American game show. He'd won more than anyone ever had in a single episode.
节目结束时，Michael Larson总共赢了110,237美元。Michael那天打破了纪录，不仅仅是《Press Your Luck》，而是任何美国游戏节目的纪录。他在单集节目中赢的钱比任何人都要多。
Congratulations. Spend it wisely. And get your daughter a lovely birthday gift.
恭喜。明智地花掉它。给你女儿买一份可爱的生日礼物。
I was happy for him. But I was worried that he might squander the money in some way.
我为他感到高兴。但我担心他可能会以某种方式挥霍掉这笔钱。
Again, Michael's brother, James.
再说一次，Michael的弟弟James。
Well yeah, I tried to get him to look at some reasonable investments, maybe buy some real estate. And he just put it into the bank, which is, I thought, a very wise move. Then after a couple of months, he took some of it out. I said, "What are you doing"? He says, "I'm trying to win this contest that they have on a radio station in Dayton. And you have to get a certain serial number".
嗯是的，我试图让他看一些合理的投资，也许买些房地产。但他只是把钱存进银行，我认为这是一种非常明智的做法。几个月后，他取出了一些。我说，“你在干什么？”他说，“我在尝试赢取他们广播电台里举行的竞赛。你必须得到一个特定的序列号。”
Every day they would give a serial number out on the radio. And if you can match that serial number on a $1 dollar bill, then you won $30,000.
他们每天会在收音机里给出一个序列号。如果你能在那张1美元纸币上匹配到那个序列号，那你就能赢30,000美元。
Again, Teresa, Michael's former wife.
再说一次，Teresa，Michael的前妻。
That intrigued him to, "Well, I should be able to do. I got more $1 bills than anybody else around here". So it took him over two weeks. And it took him five different banks to get $100,000 and bring it in. And he was bringing it in like every other day in a burlap bag. And he even carried it in in a green trash bag. The federal reserve puts $1 bills in $4,000 dollar packets on a piece of little, thin balsam wood, and it's shrink-wrapped. We had like six of those under the bed. You walk into our bedroom and you could see them all lined up under the bed.
这也吸引了他，“好吧，我应该能做到。我这里的1美元纸币比谁都多”。所以他花了两周多时间。他去了五家不同的银行取了100,000美元带进去。他每隔一天左右就用麻袋带进去。他甚至用绿色垃圾袋装着。美联储把1美元纸币存放在4,000美元一包的包装里，放在一块薄薄的轻木上，并用塑料薄膜包裹。床下我们大概有六个那样的包。你走进我们的卧室，就能看到它们整齐地排在床底下。
They also stacked hundreds of dollar bills on TVs, VCRs, the stairs, and just about everywhere else. After they had the 100 grand, they closed the shades and they hunkered down.
他们还在电视、录像机、楼梯和几乎所有地方堆放了几百张纸币。在他们有了10万现金后，他们拉上窗帘，躲在那里。
We would sit and go through this money looking for these serial numbers. You had a few days to turn it in. So we had several numbers we were looking for. It took us a weeks to go through half that money, literally go through it. Because you have to eat, and bathe, and do other things.
我们会坐下来翻阅这些钱寻找序列号。你有几天时间可以提交。所以我们有几个要寻找的号码。我们花了几周时间才翻完一半的钱，字面上是翻阅。因为你得吃饭、洗澡、做其他事情。
Day after day Michael and Teresa sorted the money into grocery bags and piles. They weren't finding the numbers the match the ones announced on the radio. So Michael put half the cash back in the bank. That left 50,000 $1 bills sitting in trash bags, hanging out of drawers, and falling out of closets. They were exhausted. So one night they took a break.
日复一日，Michael和Teresa把钱整理成杂货袋和堆。他们没找到和收音机里宣布的一样的号码。所以Michael把一半现金存回了银行。剩下50,000张1美元纸币堆在垃圾袋里，挂在抽屉外面，从壁橱里掉出来。他们筋疲力尽。所以一天晚上，他们休息了一下。
We went to a Christmas party about 8 o'clock that evening, 7:30, 8 o'clock. And we were there for a long time. When we got home, it was near 1 o'clock or something. The back door was kicked in and his cash is gone.
那天晚上8点，7:30，8点左右，我们去了个圣诞派对。我们在那里待了很长时间。当我们回家时，大概快1点了。后门被踢开了，他的现金没了。
The first thing he asked me was did I take his money. I said, "No, I didn't take your money. I was with you". "Well you had somebody do it." "No, I didn't have anybody do it".
他问我的第一件事就是我是不是拿了他的钱。我说，“不，我没拿你的钱。我一直和你在一起”。“那你叫别人拿的。”“不，我没叫别人拿。”
To this day, this robbery has never been solved. But at the time, Michael was convinced Teresa had something to do with it. The police questioned Teresa several times. They turned up nothing and gave up. Michael didn't.
直到今天，这起抢劫案仍未破获。但在当时，Michael确信Teresa与此事有关。警察审问了Teresa好几次。他们一无所获，放弃了。Michael没有放弃。
He kept watching me real close at night. And I mean he would come in and just stare at me and stuff. And I just had a feeling he was going to try to kill me. Yeah. He was going to put a gun to my head. At night while I was asleep, he'd come in and stand and just stare at me. And it gave me the creeps really bad.
他晚上一直盯着我看得很紧。我是说他会进来，只是盯着我看什么的。我只是有一种感觉他想杀我。是的。他要用枪指着我的头。晚上我睡着的时候，他会进来站在那里盯着我看。这真的让我感到非常毛骨悚然。
So one day I just decided that while he ran to the store, and that's when I got my kids, and left, and went to a hotel, ordered a couple of pieces, and we just stayed there. And I called him and told him to get out of my house.
所以有一天我决定，趁他去商店的时候，我带着孩子离开了，去了酒店，订了几间房，我们就待在那里。我打电话给他，叫他滚出我的房子。
After this point, Teresa and James say their picture of what Michael was up to is sketchy. Here's what we do know. Michael moved back to his little hometown outside Dayton, Ohio and he found a new girlfriend. In 1999, nine years after Michael's big win, Michael and this girlfriend suddenly fled Ohio.
从这一点开始，Teresa和James说他们对Michael正在做的事情的了解就很模糊了。我们确实知道的是，Michael搬回了俄亥俄州代顿外的小家乡，并找了一个新女友。1999年，在Michael大获全胜九年后，Michael和这个女友突然逃离了俄亥俄州。
Teresa and James later learned why from federal investigators. The pair was caught up in a huge scam that combined a pyramid scheme, fake investments, and Indian lotteries. Altogether 20,000 people were conned out of $3 million. It was also the first major internet fraud that the Securities and Exchange Commission ever investigated. The SEC and the FBI hundred Michael and this woman for almost four years until 1999 when Michael died in Florida from throat cancer.
Teresa和James后来从联邦调查员那里得知了原因。两人陷入了一个巨大的骗局，结合了金字塔计划、虚假投资和印度彩票。总共20,000人被骗走了300万美元。这也是美国证券交易委员会调查的第一起重大互联网欺诈案。SEC和FBI追踪了Michael和这个女人近四年，直到1999年Michael在佛罗里达州死于喉癌。
Teresa says even today she has bad feelings about how Michael treated her. After all, he accused her of taking his money. And when Michael ran away from the Feds, he left behind a son he'd had with Teresa. Because of that, it's easy to get her to say bad things about him, about the kind of person he was. That makes this one thing she said kind of surprising, which is that it actually bothers her when sometimes people say he cheated Press Your Luck out of money. They call what he did a scandal or a scam.
Teresa说即使今天，她对Michael对待她的方式仍有不好的感觉。毕竟，他指控她拿了他的钱。当Michael从联邦调查员那里逃跑时，他留下了一个他和Teresa生的儿子。正因为如此，很容易让她说他的坏话，说他是什么样的人。这使得她说的这件事有点令人惊讶，那就是当人们说他从《Press Your Luck》骗钱时，这其实让她感到困扰。他们称他的行为是丑闻或骗局。
I will say the game show is one thing he did do that was honest. He didn't cheat. There's no cheating to memorizing something. He'd sit here for six months and studied it. That was pretty amazing.
我想说这个游戏节目是他做过的一件诚实的事。他没有作弊。记住某些东西并不叫作弊。他在那里坐了六个月并研究它。这真的非常了不起。
But Michael's brother, James, still has mixed feelings about Michael's performance on Press Your Luck more than 25 years later.
但Michael的弟弟James在25年后对Michael在《Press Your Luck》上的表现仍有复杂的情绪。
Well I fell that by winning the game show, that was the start of his downfall. Him winning that large amount of money convinced him in his own mind that he could trick anybody, that he could do just about anything.
嗯，我感到赢得那个游戏节目是他堕落的开始。赢得那么大一笔钱让他自己在心里确信他可以戏耍任何人，他几乎可以做任何事。
I ask him, if there was some way for him to go back and change what happen, maybe rig the game so Michael would have lost on Press Your Luck, would he do it? James says no. He's glad Michael won. He just wishes his brother had been a different person, the kind of person who could just be happy with what he's got.
我问他，如果有什么方法能让他回去改变发生的事情，也许操纵游戏让Michael在《Press Your Luck》输掉，他会做吗？James说不会。他很高兴Michael赢了。他只是希望他弟弟能成为一个不同的人，那种能满足于所拥有的一切的人。
Michael, when you had $30,000, $40,000, $50,000, what was in your mind? Why did you keep going?
Michael，当你有了30,000，40,000，50,000美元时，你在想什么？为什么你还要继续？
Well two things, one, it felt right. And the second was I still had seven spins, and if I passed them--
嗯两件事，第一，感觉是对的。第二是我还有七次旋转，如果我跳过它们——
Shawn Allee in Chicago.
Shawn Allee在芝加哥。
[MUSIC  - "I NEED A DOLLAR" BY ALOE BLACC]
[音乐 - Aloe Blacc的《I Need a Dollar》]
Our program today was produced by Robyn Semien and me with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager, music help from Jessica Hopper, production help from Brian Reed and Shawn Wen. Mina Hochberg helped produce our story about Vietnamese sandwich shops in Brooklyn.
我们今天的节目由Robyn Semien和我制作，参与人员包括Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们的高级制作人是Julie Snyder。Seth Lind是我们的制作经理，Emily Condon是我们的办公室经理，Jessica Hopper提供了音乐帮助，Brian Reed和Shawn Wen提供了制作帮助。Mina Hochberg帮助制作了我们关于布鲁克林越南三明治店的故事。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International WBEZ. Management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia who knows that you still do not have you weekend plans totally sewn up, you don't know exactly what you're going to do still, he has a suggestion.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际WBEZ发行。我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板Torey Malatia先生负责，他知道你还没有把你的周末计划完全安排好，你还不知道你确切要做什么，他有个建议。
Just do the heroin. You already have heroine. Just do the heroin.
直接用海洛因就行了。你已经有海洛因了。直接用海洛因就行了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC  - "I NEED A DOLLAR" BY ALOE BLACC]
[音乐 - Aloe Blacc的《I Need a Dollar》]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。